David, what did you come up with?
>> So the descend-ladder
operator is pretty similar to
the climb-ladder operator.
We still have to have a dry ladder in
order to climb up or down the ladder.
This time in order to
climb down the ladder,
we have to already be on the ladder.
So our preconditions are that we are on
the ladder and the ladder is dry.
Our postcondition is that
we are now on the floor.
So we just kind of flipped
the climb ladder operator.
For paint-ceiling we know that the robot
has to already be on the ladder in order
to reach the ceiling so the precondition
here is that the robot is on the ladder.
After its painted the ceiling
we have two things,
the ceiling is now painted and
the ladder is not dry.
We haven't seen this before but
this goes back to what you were saying
Ashok about we have to explicitly negate
things that were true
in the world before.
The ceiling was dry,
but now it's not dry.
Similarly, for painting the ladder,
the robot has to be on the floor.
It can't paint the ladder
while it's standing on it.
And the post condition is that
the ladder is painted and
that the ladder is not dry.
>> This is right, David.
Let us note a couple of other things.
First, note how a precondition
logic is providing
precision to this specification or
these operators.
That's the power of logic,
it provides clarity and precision.
The other is once again note
that the preconditions have only
positive literals.
While the postconditions may
have negative literals as well.
>> So, Ashok why is it that we
can't have negative literals in
our preconditions?
Why can't we just say not painted
ladder instead of dry ladder?
>> David just has to do something
the history of these notations.
This notation comes from scripts,
a planner developed in the late 60s
at a Stanford research institute.
One of the early robot planners that ran
under ran under a robot called Shakey.
Strips the planner use tier
improving to form plans and
it turned out that the use
of only positive requals
in the preconditions made the cure
improving processes more efficient.
This conventions is just stayed in AI
since the times of strips and Shakey.